hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Museum of simulation
technology now this game was told to me
by ethan of crank gameplays who has the
crankiest crew in the West and this game
might be a little bit different than
you're expecting because it's it's a
little bit odd
it may seem simplistic at first and I
don't know too many details about the
gameplay itself but I do know about the
core fundamental aspect of the game
which is to manipulate your environment
welcome to the Museum of simulation
technology now you may see these giant
obelisks in the distance different
landmarks and stuff but what makes it
really interesting is when you grab them
they change this size and that this
isn't an illusion if I go over here and
I walk over to this thing
it is legitimately huge right now it's
it's huge if I grab it it's uh it's no
longer huge and that's how the game
works
it's like some weird weird dynamic
that's huge and in the distance oh wait
no it's not it's right here in tiny oh
look at that it's fricking tiny or is it
fricking gigantic which it is well I can
make it bigger than that whole point
Shaboom wait we can go bigger we can go
bigger we can go bigger boom
oh it's axe that's tiny itty bitty that
says itty bitty Lady Liberty over there
might be hard for him oh god that's tiny
oh whoops well I done goofed on that one
I don't have to fix that ooh boy
alright well it's a little bit bigger
than it was yeesh I don't know how to
make that any smaller see if I can make
this any bigger soon Oh
too big defense Wow op goofing around
here so this is what the fundamental
principle of the game is it's all about
changing the dynamic sizes of these
objects including this one
boom okay go anyway so I don't that's
the only part that I know about the game
and that's what really blew my mind when
I heard about this game oh I get to be
puzzled many kitchen appliances exhibit
oh it's delightful or is it or is it
gigantic oh that's so cool oh that's so
cool okay so I gotta like like from I
got to move back and then suddenly it's
going to be as big as I need it to be or
bigger oh that's so cool how high can I
jump here okay so this is workable so
then I just got to make everything that
I need up to the staircase to the exit
and that's the basic principle of the
game and that's so fascinating like I
know it's probably just a clever
programming trick but even so just
because it's a clever programming trick
does not mean that that's frickin
fascinating like that's legitimately
fascinating oh no I'm blocked from it
why am i blocked but still oh my god
it's so cool it's just like I don't know
it's something like that it's clever
gaming mechanics wrapped in a wrapper
that does not seem that convoluted this
seems like very simplistic graphics and
gameplay but even so oh hi Mona Lisa can
you oh maybe I can build like a ramp or
something yeah not quite enough there we
go oh okay so I got the slant I just got
to make it bigger my laser hammer
Hey yup that gonna work for me huh
beauty hard-baked gimme finally buy
party bait
thank you and just like that you use the
entire environment to make your way
would and just like that
you use the entire run like a goddamn ax
and just like that you use the entire
momentum to be able to move through the
level and thusly if I've got this right
can I take this one yes I can alright
good oh that's awesome
that's awesome but it kind of got
flubber nuk can you not be fob or nook
all right well that's blocked literally
no no no oh god damn it
well shitty tits alright we're working
with something there ah so close but I
might be able to work with this I might
have gotten this on the first go and I
didn't realize it yep hi okay easy peasy
lemon squeeze me okay
sides of whoo that is a bit of death
that's a big-ass bit of death
am I supposed to use that to my
advantage or something
oh crap oh boy that's not gonna work is
okay what if I just make it so bag
I made it tidy
goddamnit all the Momentum's a little
stanky on here damn it
ah final restart oh it's pointed me
that's awfully convenient of it okay so
I just got to make it big enough
boink that it land yes
lost that one grab your big now grab
your big now whoa grab your ridiculously
big now whoa how close am I to the edge
whoa ho boy that's too big that's way
too big oh boy oh boy
ah it went right down the hole
god dammit that's more like it oh god
damn it right at the hole across the
bridge ah right in the goddamn hole ah I
see you didn't even need it it jumped
across well alright then I'm dumb
I love the smooth child oh maybe I can
use this like what if I am able to use
this fan and it'll blow me
you're good blowing me can you blow me
harder please pretty please all I've
ever wanted I tip it can I tip it can I
tip it can I tip it come on tip baby tip
for me oh my face
I got damn it get off my head oh oh when
I was awfully convenient thank you I
didn't know I could do that I didn't
even consider that to be an option
whoa if an object is outlined in blue
right click to rotate oh yes please
come on get me into space all I got a
space that's up the moon
oh well whatever it's good enough damn
it let me on not the way I wanted to
rotate like and thusly whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa blocks goddammit
goddammit too big that might be -
honking huge oh oh that's a brigand oh I
felt bryggen I'm not gonna be able to
get to the tip top of that though they
sit up blink oh boy
that's really big whoa that's too big oh
boy
I made that big oh I made that big whoa
let's just restart that one maybe that's
a pretty steep grade though I don't know
if I can climb that one that's like
really see oh my god maybe I can Oh
Teddy Ted Kat come on come on get it oh
I'm jumping so much yeah I don't know
about this one i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i
anybody know oh boy whoa whoa
flow flow flow flow don't fail me now
don't fail me now don't fail me now
don't fail me now
well okay was I supposed to do that I
don't know if I was supposed to do that
but I did that oh so um
Hey alrighty then we what do I do and
where do I go and let's not momentum are
way off of this thing let's just die you
know I'll come on really there no no
exit what oh hey that's rude okay
goodbye man I guess oh oh oh what the
hell
wait a minute I didn't even know you
could grab that Oh what what
is that the exit what hell oh man okay I
was going the wrong way the whole time
oh my god all right good enough I think
I can fly through there holy I
didn't even know I did not know you
could grab the moon there I was being a
big dumb idiot holy oh my god oh my
god my god oh my god oh that's awesome
oh not okay they're now putting mirrors
in this and I'm not okay with
it oh boy oh boy oh boy oh what the
oh hi what's up there oh god I'm in a
different y'all my god oh boy oh boy oh
god this place is so big oh I didn't
mean for this happen oh I need to make
it smaller not bigger this needs to be
through lipping huge and this is perfect
oh there we go so this is gonna be not
quite yet but there we go and shoot okay
we're not yet not yet well okay get down
there shabu key okay that's perfectly
into wool perfectly normal-sized what
happens if I make this unbelievably huge
I guess I can't okay I get it I get it I
get it
Oh
okay alright just like that that's big
this is normal
huge oh my god oh I love it oh I love it
I love it I'm happy too big not just the
right size
oh that's it oh okay so this is just a
demo of a game that's going to be coming
out later this is a demo that just shows
a lot of potential in the uniqueness of
what can be done in a game it's kind of
like that last bit was kind of portal
esque but just the mechanic of changing
the shape based on perspective kind of
like warps your brain on what actually
is reality it's insane but I
love it so thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed this let
me know what you think of it down in the
comments below and I'll try to link to
the game in the description if you want
to try for yourself so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]